kind of interesting isn't it they said
it was price gouging because those
people were terrified we'll talk about a
person who needs a new heart they're
terrified
$750,000 we should put those doctors in
jail but we bow to them because oh
that's high-tech medicine out of 270
million people in America you save about
50 a year is that cost effective I don't
think so I don't think so any rate Dr
Stewart burer didn't have expensive
urine and here's the last one and many
of you may know this woman uh her name
was Dr Gail Clark she was aged 47 she
was the chief cardiologist of the West
St Louis County group of hospitals uh
she was the chief cardiologist for the
um St Mary's Health Center in Richmond
Heights in St Louis County she was aged
47 guess what she died from heart attack
a cardiopathy heart attack you can just
see her walking down the hall she's got
the stethoscope around her neck you know
this is their little status symbol got
my stethoscope around my neck back when
I was in school they folded it up very
bravely and put it in their pocket
boom she falls down she has a heart
attack right in the hall and of course
the nurses scoop her up and put her on a
gurnie and they call the technicians and
another doctor code three code three
code blue whatever it is and they whiper
into the room and you can hear them
let's say you're a cardiac patient
you're laying there you're all hooked up
to the monitors and the IVs and and you
hear them say Okay tear clothes off okay
stand back didn't work turn it up stand
back and then you hear that terrible
sound when you know that the treatment
didn't work hey
the Flatline when you know the heart is
gone and everybody walks out of the room
dejected and you say nurse nurse what
happened next door and she says well
your cardiologist you know the chief
cardiologist of this Hospital age 47 Dr
Gail Clark just died of a cardiomyopathy
heart attack you can see all the
patients they're holding their
gowns and they're running out of that
hospital leaving their watches and their
shoes and their checkbooks and
everything and their plastic credit
cards cuz they don't want to get what Dr
Gail Clark
got to me the reader digest is a
magazine that never says anything
negative or bad about anybody or any
group it's the sweetest little magazine
that ever was the September 1993 issue
features an article it says can you
trust your
doctor it list 12 ways that doctors scam
your money and I'll let you read 11 of
them yourself I'll give you the worst
one in addition to their income from
Office fees and surgical fees and lab
fees and hospitalization in addition to
all those fees doctors get a kickback
from the labs and the the X-ray labs and
Clinics and hospitals they get a
kickback of
$421 every time they send you in for a
CAT scan or an
MRI and doctors tell you oh we do that
because we're practicing defensive
medicine because if I miss something you
know one in 10 billion you're going to
sue me so I do this just to protect
myself well if it was just to protect
themselves and you knew them and they
knew you 90% of the people say I'll just
skip it DOC if you don't really think
it's necessary let's to save the
money but they got something more than
defensive medicine to worry about they
get 421 bucks in a kickback for every
time they send you in for an MRI or a
CAT scan well when I practiced for 12
years up in Portland somebody come to me
with a terrible headache never had one
I'd just walk up to them and tap them on
the sinuses and if they collapsed to
their knees I know they had a sinus
headache oh doc why'd you do that well I
just want that's a cheap lab test you
know
if they had thank
you if they had blood dripping out of
their
nose if they had blood dripping out of
their nose it take a $35 x-ray to see if
they had a cancer in
there 35 bucks in a free lab test as
opposed to 421 bucks if I wanted to make
that 421 bucks I'd have been a good
Thief what I'd have done I'd have build
a chute right into that cat scan machine
cuz I knew how to build shoots living on
a farm and I'd have gone out in the
street and I'd have got every homeless
person I'd line them up in them shoots
and I'd put soup in a MIG Mac at the end
of that tube you know and I'd say I'm
going to give buy you $150 dinner I'm a
good guy I'm going to buy you a $150
dinner you just got to go through the
shoot go through that tube and you get
your sandwich and your soup man they'd
be flowing through there maybe a hundred
a day and I could start adding some
things up it'd be a lot of fun any rate
the average doctor gets
$228,600 a year in cat scan Kickbacks a
quarter of a million dollars a year and
any other industry if you do that
politicians
lawyers
businessmen stock Brokers they get put
in jail but doctors it's
okay because insurance pays for it
Hillary will pay for it we don't mind if
they steal it's blind it's free well I
remember I told you I was going to tell
you about
Pica Pica is a funny disease Pica I'm
not talking about the type style that
you see in typewriters and computers but
p is a disease that farmers know about
uh in horses it's called cribbing when
they chew on the feed bunk the wooden
feed bunk you know you better give them
some minerals otherwise they're going to
eat that feed bunk also uh in cattle
dairy cattle especially where they're
losing lots of minerals through their
milk all the time intensive milking
you'll see them picking up big rocks in
the creek and chewing on them or they'll
chew on Bob wire or maybe you'll see
them walking down through a path with a
deer bone in their mouth or something or
a shingle that's called Pica and a good
farmer husbandry know you better give
them some minerals otherwise they're
going to eat the barn or something in
human beings we see this at funny times
pregnant women are notorious for Pika uh
in the middle of the night they'll elbow
their husband and say Hey you better get
up I want some uh pickles and ice cream
they're craving minerals because that
fetus is pulling minerals out of their
body they need some more minerals and so
it's it's recognized as a craving for
things like sweets and salt and so forth
we see this in pregnant women I used to
have people come to my practice and they
say do do I need to go see a shrink as
wise is that well I wake up in the
middle of the night and I I go outside
with a spoon and I eat dirt and no
that's okay just make sure it's clean
dirt then they say my my kid sits there
with a kitty litter box between his legs
and has a spoon and he's eating that
stuff out of the kitty litter box and
then in housing projects little kids
will eat lead paint off the walls and
they get lead poison get learning
disabilities and Bone problems and
anemia and we're good so we spend $5
million to scrape the lead paint off of
there and repaint it with latex paint
and all you have to do is give those
kids 10 cents a day worth of minerals
it' be better for them and save us 5
million bucks it's your tax
money and if we allow them to throw them
away those dollars is kind of
interesting any rate if you have a
selenium deficiency and you don't want
to wait until you get cardiopathy and
drop dead from a heart attack to
recognize it if you look on your hands
and look in the mirror in your face if
you have liver spots or age spots and I
see quite a few from here
you have an early selenium deficiency
that's called free radical damage and
fortunately for you if you recognize
that and you start taking in some
colloidal selenium in four to 6 months
those will all go away you'll reverse
that in four to 6 months and when they
go away on the outside they're going
away on the inside your brain and your
heart and your liver and your kidneys
then if you have low blood sugar how
many in this room have low blood sugar
anybody in here have low blood sugar
okay about 10% how many you ever seen a
hyperactive kid who gets on
sugar okay about every body in the room
people who have sugar problems are like
alcoholics there's good ones and bad
ones you know the good alcoholics are
one when they get two drinks they just
go off in a Conner and go to sleep right
same way with somebody with low blood
sugar they eat a big meal or they eat a
piece of pie three hours later they
clunk out and go to sleep then there's
bad alcoholics they're the one that gets
two drinks in them and they get violent
and raged and they want to fight
everybody they punch holes in the wall
you know B big Brave fellows and they
kick their wife and kick the dog and
take the chainsaw and cut their
neighbor's tree down and all these wild
things and drive Reckless down the roads
and kill people those are the bad drunks
well people who have blood sugar
problems are bad blood sugar people too
they get a little crazy okay I don't
know how many of you remember the
twinkie
defense right remember somebody murdered
two people and he claimed he ate a
Twinkie three hours before he murdered
him so they let him off because he got
temporarily insane every time he ate
sugar now don't any of you try
that well chromium and vadium deficien
will result in these sugar problems low
blood sugar and if you let it go on for
any length of time you develop diabetes
chromium and vadium then a tin
deficiency the early symptoms of a tin
deficiency are male pattern baldness I
see a lot of tin deficiency in this room
yes and if you let it go on for any
length of time you get
deafness then there's a boron deficiency
and you gal should know about boron
because it helps you keep the calcium
you take in in your bones so you don't
get out iosis
Boron also it helps you make estrogen it
helps you fellas make testosterone if
you don't take in enough Boron you
ladies are going to suffer miserably
going through menopause okay you're
going to have all those terrible
symptoms you fellas don't get enough
Boron can't make testosterone you won't
know whether to lead or follow on the
Dance
Floor you're going to be
confused she saying he's got a boron
deficiency then in laboratory oh I
should tell you too we said this on the
show today those of you may not have
heard it some of you didn't hear the
whole show the first symptoms of a zinc
deficiency is you lose your sense of
smell and your taste you say oh you know
food just doesn't taste good anymore and
you don't have a cold or anything like
that and you say your wife says well
aren't you excited about dinner I spent
the whole day in the kitchen cooking
dinner he said well I didn't smell
anything when I walked in you know he's
got a zinc deficiency well in laboratory
animals there's some seven rare Earths
these rare Earths are trace minerals you
need in lesser amounts than you need
trace minerals and they actually double
the lifespan of laboratory animals
they've not been proven in humans yet
but I'm not going to wait 500 years for
doctors to approve it they're still
arguing over vitamin C and calcium right
so I'm just going to do it didn't kill
any laboratory animals just doubles her
life and it's not a drug these rare
Earths are called lanthum prium neodium
samarium europium yium and thulium
there must be a reason why they're named
after Old Testament cities well remember
I told you we needed 90 nutrients we
need 60 minerals we need 16 vitamins 12
essential amino acids and three
essential fatty acids and of course
we're lucky in that plants as a group
can make most vitamins amino acids and
fatty acids plants can do that because
they just take carbon out of the air and
make carbon chains to make vitamins
amino acids and fatty acids but you have
to eat 15 to 25 different plants a day
in the right combinations to make this
happen theoretically it's possible but
most Americans don't do it the average
American thinks if they eat some potato
buds out of a Betty Crocker box or
eating a vegetable okay so you got to be
careful what you're considering a
vegetable then of course people want to
do right by their doctor and they eat
lowfat turkey breast and they put a half
a jar of mayonnaise on there and they
put it between two slices of Wonder
styrofoam bread remember that stuff you
can insulate your house with and put in
your shoes when you get a hole in shoe I
remember when I was a kid 50 years ago
it was a lot of fun because we have
Wonderbread we didn't have TVs back then
on the farm we didn't even have dryers
that went round and round so the only
thing you could do in the winter time
was sit in the kitchen and wand at a
loaf of Wonderbread and it had the blue
and red and green yellow balloons on
there and if you read the label as many
times as I do you know it said things
like helps build bodies at 12 ways and
about 15 years later the FDA made him
change it to help build your body eight
ways now if you go to the store and look
at Wonderbread wrappers it just says
Wonder under bread so it kind of gives
you a
clue so even though this is
theoretically possible it's not likely
to happen that you're going to get your
vitamins amino acids and fatty acids in
proper proportions from your diet and so
if your life is as valuable to you as
mine is to me and my children's and my
grandchildren's is to me I would make
sure that I take in all my vitamins and
amino acids and fatty acids because I
guarantee you won't make it to 120 or
140 if you don't
you're just not going to do it now
minerals are another story we have a
tragic story when it comes to minerals
because plants cannot make minerals in
any way shape or form and if they're not
in the soil anymore they're not in our
plants we have for you when you leave a
free copy of a summary of US Senate
document 264 US Senate document 264 is
from the 74th Congress second session
and it says that our farm soils and our
rain soils are depleted of minerals and
the crops the grains the fruits and the
vegetables and the nuts that are grown
on these depleted farm and Rain soils
are minerally deficient the people who
eat them get mineral deficiency diseases
and the only way to prevent and cure
them is with mineral supplements as US
Senate document 264 74th Congress second
session it was written and printed by
the US Congress in
1936 58 years ago do you think it's
gotten any better no it has not gotten
any better it's only gotten worse and
the reason is if you guys do what we did
and people continue to do is we put NPK
on our land nitrogen phosphorus
potassium and you see it as these three
numbers and many combinations of of um
ratios and these represent percentages
of these three nutrients nitrogen
phosphorus potassium and those of you
who don't have any experience on farms
the reason why we do this is farmers get
paid for tons and bushels there's no
subsidy that encourages people to put 60
minerals back in the soil you get paid
for tons and bushels and for 40 an acre
you can get the maximum yield in tons
and bushels it only takes 5 to 10 years
to deplete the land of minerals because
every time you harvest a crop those
plants pull minerals out of the soil
many pounds per acre every time you haul
a crop out so soon those minerals are
gone and if you only put back in three
and you take out 60 it's like a checking
account if you only put three bucks in
your checking account every month and
write checks for 60 what's going to
happen to your checks boing boing boing
they bounce exactly like can tell you
that our health is bouncing right now to
the tune of $1.2 trillion dollar a year
because there's no more minerals left in
our soil it's our responsibility each
and every one of us to be responsible
for our health and consciously take in
these minerals I have a lot of people
ask me what did these people do
thousands of years ago they didn't even
have commercial fertilizers what did
they do these societies that had longli
people and whatnot I want you to think
about the Egyptians the Chinese uh
people from India that lived around
these Great Rivers the Nile River the
Ganges River um the yo river in China
and what used to happen was every year
or so it would flood just like it did
here in Northern Missouri last year and
every time it flooded guess what would
happen it would bring silt or rock dust
from Mountains from 500 or thousand
miles away and those people would pray
to every God they had the water God the
sky God the wind God The Rock God to
flood we pray don't flood they used to
pray to flood because they had their
floods during the winter time and would
put silt and minerals back in the soil
and their grain was very valuable King
Phillip who is the father of uh
Alexander the Great married the
12-year-old child queen of Egypt
Cleopatra she didn't look like Elizabeth
Taylor all made up and beautiful
costumes she was a little flatchested
teeny bopper not very sexy but Philip
married her because she controlled the
best wheat in the world and if he wanted
his Macedonian army to conquer the world
through his son Alexander the great he
needed the best wheat in the world so he
could March 20 hours a day fight for 6
hours and win if they used the wheat
from the depleted soils in Greece they
couldn't go 20 minutes without saying
mommy pick me up can you imagine these
big Greek soldiers Oh my legs hurt pick
me up and so they knew the best place to
get wheat was from
Egypt it was those floods that gave them
those minerals and all those cultures
that came up with all the great art and
all the great technology came from those
PE places because they had more
intelligence cuz it had more nutrition
more minerals I heard somebody say very
good well you're getting the picture
well what I'm going to do here is I'm
just going to pick out a couple of
minerals just a couple of them so you
get the idea it applies to all of them
let's just pick out a common one like
calcium everybody knows about calcium
Calcium deficiency will result in
something like 147 different diseases
they're just different names they're
named after people like Bells paly
Bell's paly is you know everybody knows
about that one side of your face sags
it's not a true stroke it just affects
your facial muscles it's caused by
Calcium deficiency we'll talk about in a
little bit but everybody knows about
this one osteoporosis it's the number 10
killer of adults United States it's very
expensive it costs you $35,000 each for
each hip to replace it's okay it's
free insurance or Medicare or Hillary
will'll pay for it cost you $70,000 for
both hips as expensive as it is and
number 10 killer remember Mrs ski from
Radford Virginia aged 115 years of age
she died of complications of a fall we
don't have osteoporosis and animals and
it's because of farmers we don't have
osteoporosis and animals goes like this
you have a a pasture with a 100 cows in
it and this year you didn't have any
calves you can't repay your operating
loan you're in trouble right because you
paid for the feed and the vet bill and
mowed the pasture and fertilize and
maintain the fence and fed the cows and
all this that and the other
you don't have any cash you can't pay
back the oper operating load and make
any money so you call the vet out and
you say do I get rid of these cows what
happened here and he examines the cow he
says nothing wrong with them says let me
look at the bull he says aha here's your
problem that bull has osteoporosis of
both hips can't breede the cows didn't
have any calves he says I'll tell you
what though he says you give me $70,000
he says I'll put two new hips in that
bull next year you'll have some calvs
well the first thing that farmer says is
stand back doc boom
he blows that bull away with a deer
rifle and while the kids are grinding
the kid uh the uh well the kids are
grinding the bull up with um a grinder
and cut and roast and steaks off that
bull the farmer is chewing on a straw
and saying now Doc pushes Stetson up a
little bit and he says you know he says
uh you know I wasn't going to pay you
$70,000 for that old bull he says I get
a new bull every year for 70 years for
that he says but every once in a while I
get a bull that throws good calves I'd
like to keep them is there any way I can
prevent that oste prosis thing for
happen to a good bull he says well yeah
he says if you'll give a bull calf 10
cents worth of calcium every day after
he's weaned he'll never get osteoporosis
for say now wait a minute doc you mean
if I give that bull 10 cents a day worth
of calcium from the time he's weaned I
can prevent a
$70,000 disaster oh yeah it's that
simple he says you mean all I have to do
is give up a half a cup of coffee a day
to do that he says yeah that's it he
says I choose that one he say I'll give
up the half a cup of coffee and that's
what we have to think like okay then
there's receding
gums dentist and periodontist will tell
you that if you want to prevent and cure
receding gums you better floss and brush
after every meal if you believe that
works I have some oceanfront property in
Montana to sell you if you all know your
geography you know that doesn't work now
as a veterinarian I've seen hundreds of
thousands of animals of all kinds mice
rats rabbits dogs cats sheep pigs hor
lions and tigers and bears and they
don't get receding gums and they don't
floss now they do get funky breath but
they don't get receding gums boy if you
want to smell something you just let a
camel breathe on you
boy well the reason we don't have
receding gums and livestock is because
we've dealt with the osteoporosis
problem receding gums is not a
deficiency of flossing it's in fact
osteoporosis of the jaw bones and of the
face facial bone so if you have
gingivitis or receding gums you have
advanced osteoporosis those bones around
your teeth are melting away little bit
by little bit every day and if you take
your teeth out at night and put them in
a glass next to your bed and that fizzy
stuff you have major advanced
osteoporosis because all your bone has
melted away okay then there's
arthritis we talked about that a little
bit earlier remember the chicken
cartilage or the nox gelatin 85% of all
arthritis is caused by osteoporosis of
the joint ends of the bones you're
talking about degenerative arthritis
osteoarthritis sciatica lumbago
rheumatism all those sorts of things um
they're caused by osteoporosis of the
joint ends of the bones I want you to
think about something for a minute if
you don't take a pain reliever or or an
anti-inflammatory for that arthritis
let's say you get arthritis of the hips
you're going to kind of favor that a
little bit aren't you you're going to
get a cane or a walker or crutches
you're going to favor it and so you
don't put any weight on it I want you to
think about that for just a second
because then I want you to think about
driving your tractor in a field or
you're driving a Mercedes down the
highway either one doesn't matter
whichever you love
more and um let's say you didn't put the
nut on that oil pan real tight and all
the oil drained out and that light on
the dashboard comes on and says I'm
getting hot you better give me some oil
and that light irritates you so you stop
you open up the hood you get your
clippers out you know your fence
Clippers and you clip the the wire to
that light and you close the hood and
you just keep driving would you do that
to your tractor or your Mercedes no you
wouldn't but we take those pain
relievers for arthritis and we go out
there and square dance and do the Texas
step and do our five mile walks and our
aerobics that pill Works real good doc
cuz it killed my pain and you're just
wearing that thing off faster and
faster then your doctor is really going
to get rich because you need joint
replacement
surgery then there's hypertension this
is one of my favorites I'll put put a
star over
here hypertension is high blood pressure
what's the first nutritional thing that
a doctor will tell you to give up
nutritionally when you get high blood
pressure give up salt everybody knows
that one that's been ingrained in our
head well they must think we're dumber
than cows because what's the first thing
you put out for your livestock and it's
about that big a salt block no farmer is
going to be economically viable if you
don't put a salt block out for your
livestock they're going to die kind your
Veterinary bills are going to go crazy
but we're supposed to believe that we
don't need salt and you can get
everything you need out of your lettuce
and your whole wheat bread and stuff
like that well don't believe that one
either if you believe that I got some
more ocean front property in Montana for
you remember those long live people put
a big chunk of rock salt the size of a
big black concord grape and every cup of
tea and they drink about 40 Cups of Tea
a day because they live at high
altitudes where it's very dry they have
to keep hydrated and they put butter in
their tea they put two Pats of butter
and a chunk of rock salt they don't the
pink stuff or the blue stuff or skim
milk or what does they call it uh creora
or whatever it
is okay guess guess what the doctors who
live to be 58 tell you no salt no butter
the people who live to be0 they put in
butter and salt so you got to make some
choices well they took $30 million of
your tax money and two years ago after a
20-year study they came out and said
that they took 5,000 people with high
blood pressure they took them off their
medication and put them on a reduced
salt diet a restricted salt diet and
they all died no big surprise but
somebody got a PhD degree and everybody
was happy right but when they looked at
this results they said that oh only
99.7% of the people didn't get any
results from that before they died 0.3%
did get some result dropped their blood
pressure one point before they died by
restricting their salt so the referees
who judged that article said oh doesn't
matter you might as well let high blood
pressure patients eat salt Ed peanuts
and deal pickles and salt their food to
taste because it doesn't matter in fact
worrying about the salt is more stress
than taking the salt then they had a
control group with 5,000 people with
high blood pressure and they doubled
their RDA of calcium and they stopped
the experiment in 6 weeks because 85% of
them were cured of their high blood
pressure just by doubling their calcium
intake now they didn't cold turkey stop
their high blood pressure medication but
what they did was they went to the
doctor and says you don't need this
medication anymore what are you doing
well I'm on this experiment where I
double my calcium intake anybody get a
recall notice from your doctor saying
it's okay to Salt your food to taste and
please do double your calcium intake
anybody get that not a single one that's
very interesting then of course there's
insomnia that's where you roll around
all night and you get your you wake up
in the morning you're more tired when
you went to bed that's insomnia of
course doctors have two treatments for
that they have hion which is a sleeping
pill and they have barbituates they kill
about 10,000 people a year with over
overdoses of those things but that's
okay it's a prescription and they're
watching out for us and remember
remember uh George Bush when he went to
Japan they gave him some helon so he
could sleep on the way to Japan because
of the time difference and when he woke
up one of the the side effects of helon
is nausey and
vomiting I don't know how you say it in
Japanese but it was very dramatic on
world TV right not very
presidential and so I'm sure that's why
he lost the election because he puked
over that Japanese
Ambassador and then of course there's
kidney
stones and then there's bone spurs heel
spurs and calcium deposits again
Physicians will tell you the first thing
to give up nutritionally is calcium and
dairy because they have this foolish
belief the stupid belief the ignorant
belief that the calcium and KY Stones
bone spurs heel spurs and calcium
deposits come from uh your diet when
instead it only comes from your bones
when you have a raging osteoporosis and
when you get these things you need more
calcium not less then there's cramps and
Twitches you wake up in the middle of
the night and your foot is all cramped
up around your neck and you say Lord
take me from the knee down I'm not going
to make it till morning we've all
experienced that that's very
common then there's PMS premenstrual
syndrome you know the emotional and
physical stuff the medical treatment of
choice for PMS is what we call a
hysterical ectomy it's been shortened to
hysterctomy that's a 100- year old
treatment the doctors do about 285,000
unnecessary hysterical ectomies a year
but it makes Mercedes payments so they
do them even the AMA said they're
unnecessary but they don't take their
licenses away and people keep going to
them you imagine a poor woman in her 30s
she says doc you got to do something
every time I go out to hang out the
clothes my neighbors kids run down the
basement screaming witch my own kids
think I'm crazy my husband's leaving me
I'm going to lose my job you got to do
something well the University of
California San Diego came out three
years ago now and said if you just
double the RDA of calcium intake you get
rid of 85% of the emotional and physical
symptoms of
PMs and when that came out there were
huge lines around the hell food stores
around the blocks and people had
sleeping bags because they closed before
they all got their calcium and every
person in line was a man
they were there for their daughters and
their girlfriends and their wives and
things like
that okay and lastly is low back pain
85% of Americans get low back pain
whether you work on a computer or you
unload hay or you drive big trucks
doesn't matter low back is a big problem
low back is just osteoporosis of the
vertebrae whether you have a disc
problem or whatnot because if your disc
doesn't have anything to hold on to your
vertebrae have melted away what's going
to happen happen to the disc especially
if you have a copper deficiency because
they're made out of elastic fibers they
go like a water balloon with a lot of
pressure on them well I just want you to
look at this quickly before we do the
last mineral low back you go to an
orthopedic surgeon or rheumatologist you
might get a muscle relaxant you might
get valium and a muscle relaxant you get
a laminectomy you get your vertebrae
fuse you might get a disc operation they
don't tell you 75% of the time you'll
never be the same again right PMS you go
to your
OBGYN you can um go to an internist you
can go to a family counselor a shrink or
divorce attorney cramps and Twitches you
go to a neurologist you go to a sports
medicine doctor an internist bone spurs
heel spurs calcium deposits you go to a
rheumatologist an orthopedic surgeon or
a podiatrist kidney stones you go to a
urologist or an internist or a surgeon
insomnia you go to a shrink or a um
Sleep Clinic or an internist
hypertension you go to a Cardiologist an
internist or a surgeon arthritis a
rheumatologist a orthopedic surgeon or
an internist receding gums you go to a
dentist or periodontist osteoporosis you
go to all those Health Specialists
including a tum salesman for nothing
more than a Calcium deficiency it cost
you 10 cents a day to deal with now on
the average because Americans have
insurance and we have Medicare and
Medicaid we spend on the average $25,000
to
$250,000 and we undergo five to 10
surgical procedures a year for a Calcium
deficiency and we beg the doctors to do
it we beg the doctors to do it well it's
our choice the last one I'll share with
you is diabetes everybody's touched by
diabetes it's the number three cause of
death in adults in the United States
number three cause of death and it has
terrible complications and side effects
diabetes the side effects include
blindness of many
kinds then there's a kidney failure with
dialysis and kidney transplant there's
cardiovascular disease of all kinds and
of course that contributes the number
one cause of death which is the number
one cause of death uh then there is
amputations everybody ought to have one
of those because they're totally paid
for in their health thing they assume
that you're not just going to get one
because you want to get everything on
your health benefits and then you
shorten your life because if you have
diabetes on the average you have a
shorter lifespan than someone who
doesn't have diabetes Now we learned in
1957 in the animal industry that we
could prevent and cure diabetes with two
trace minerals that's pretty profound
statement that we could prevent and cure
diabetes with two trace minerals in 1957
and animals it was published in
Federation proceedings which is the
official Journal of the American Science
the National Institutes of Health the
official monthly Journal was August
1957 well the two trace minerals that
you can get to prevent and cure this are
chrom ium and vadium vadium alone
according to the University of Vancouver
British Columbia Medical School vadium
alone will replace
insulin in adult onset diabetics which
represent 85% of all diabetics of course
they can't quit their insulin cold
turkey they got to gradually wean off of
it takes four to six months for most
people to slowly wean off of insulin if
they're taking in adequate amounts of
chromium and vadium I've seen it work on
hundreds and hundreds of people now to
me this is Criminal because if you write
to a Hills packing company that makes
signs. dog food right over here in
Topeka Kansas I don't know if I'm
pointing West but that way okay they're
all saying that
way TOA Kansas they manufacture Science
Diet dog food and other Science Diet
product high-tech foods for Animals if
you write them and say how many minerals
exactly is in Science Diet for dog food
they'll write you back and say there's
40 minerals you write checkerboard
Square in St Louis R and say just how
many minerals are in your rat pellets
for laboratory rats and they'll say
there's 28
minerals I'll give anybody in this room
a crisp new $100 bill if you can find me
a human infant formula in a grocery
store that has more than 11 so our dogs
get farty minerals remember that's what
Mike Murphy was saying his dog never
seems to get sick CU he's getting this
canned dog food with all these vitamins
and minerals in there so our dogs get
farty minerals our rats get 28 minerals
and our human infants get
11 is that fair no that's called
fraud doesn't matter if you're talking
about SMA Similac Isomil Pro soy B fact
that's why they call Similac Similac
because it lacks
everything okay if I've convinced you
that you have to consciously take in all
the minerals yourself that you can't
depend on your food and certainly can't
depend on anything that's boxed or
packaged or bottled there's three types
of min mineral that you have to be
concerned about one is metallic minerals
and metallic minerals are essentially
groundup rocks metallic minerals are
things like oyster shell eggshell
Dolomite Limestone uh calcium carbonate
Clays of various kinds Mount marinite
clay seabed minerals they're
Tums they're only 8 to 12% absorbable
When You Reach age 35 to 40 it drops
down to 3 to
5% and I have to tell you a story here
some of you heard this on the show today
I ran into a guy at a meeting like this
up at Grand Rapids Michigan and this
fellow owns a portapotty business you
know that's that green or blue colored
ouse man if we' only had one of those
back when I was a kid we had these ones
with splinters you know in the in the
wood any rate um he said I see some
something that that describes that in my
portapotty business I said what's that
he says well we take those things back
to the shop to clean them out with a
pressure hose he says we put a quarter
inch grid underneath them because kids
throw rocks and sticks and toys in there
and if we don't put a grid there it
blocks up the sewer system it cost us
thousands of dollars to fix it he says
every time we clean one of those out we
find hundreds of vitamin tablets I said
well how do you know they're vitamin
tablets he says well that's really easy
he says right on the coating it says
SRAM M One A Day
Centrum he says come here he takes me
out in the back of his shot and there's
this literal mountain of all these
vitamin pills he got out of his porta
potties that's because you can't absorb
metallic minerals if you read the labels
on those multiples they say your iron
comes in the form of iron oxide what is
iron oxide
rust you might as well just go out to an
old railroad track and take your butter
knife and scrape some of that rust off
and lick it and you're going to get your
iron supplement but that's what they're
giving you well I'll show you how bad it
is if you take something like calcium
lactate was which is a common metallic
mineral uh let's say it's a calcium tab
calcium lactate 1,000 mg if you take two
of those you're not getting 2,000 Mig of
calcium in fact I have people all the
time say well I took lots of calcium doc
I hear you on the radio talking about
calcium and arthritis and I took 2,000
milligrams of calcium a day didn't help
my arthritis in fact it got worse and so
what kind of calcium you taken they said
calcium lactate well there's your
problem because only 250 milligrams of
that is metallic calcium so let's say
you absorb 10% of that then the other
750 Mig is lactose or milk sugar
so 10% of
250 is 25 so if you take two of those
tablets you're not getting 2,000 you're
getting 50
milligrams so to get what you need you
need to take 90 of those tablets a day
you need to take 30 with each meal and
you got 59 more minerals to
go then there's those people who want to
do things naturally let's see if you can
do anything good with 10 pounds of
spinach and let's be fair let's see if
you can get 1,000 milligrams of
magnesium I pick magnesium because green
leafy vegetables you have a lot of
magnesium because of the chlorophyll
right it's part of the chlorophyll
molecule and any pound of anything you
got 454 gram and 10 lbs of spinach you
got 4540 gram of which most of that 97%
is water let's say you have 1 gram of
chlorophyll in that 10 lbs of spinach
there's 50 milligrams of magnesium you
got to divide that into the Thousand you
want you get a factor of 20 which you
multiply times the 10 you have to eat
200 lb of spinach you got 58 more
minerals to
go okay so you got to be a pretty big
person to accomplish all this even as
big as I am you can't get it done so I
prefer to supplement rather than do
those things then of course during the
60s the agricultural industry came up
with teated minerals key minerals
because Farmers aren't dumb enough to
pay for a dollar of something that goes
into an animal's mouth and have 99 Cents
come out in the manure so I have to
really thank Farmers for being that
clever and chelated minerals are just
metallic minerals with an amino acid or
protein or enzyme wrapped around the
metal atom and increase the
absorbability to 40% then the hell food
industry jumped on that right away
because it was a major Improvement in
absorbability of minerals the most
efficient way to absorb minerals is the
colloidal Farm colloidal minerals are
98% absorbable 2 and a half times more
available than chelated minerals and 10
times more available than metallic
minerals and they're very interesting
they're liquid they can only be liquid
can't be pills powders or uh capsules
they're very small particle size are
7,000 times smaller than a red blood
cell and they're negatively charged
every particle is negatively charged
your intestinal lining is positively
charged so you actually have an
electrical or magnetic gradient that
concentrates these minerals around the
lining of your intestin these three
things together give you the 98%
absorbability now plants have a very
interesting part to play in colloidal
minerals remember we said that plants
cannot create minerals if they're not in
the soil plants can't make them remember
that US Senate document 264 says they're
not in the soil anymore at any rate
metallic minerals are taken up by plants
when they're in the soil plants convert
them in their tissues to colloidal
minerals and this is how we store
minerals in our body this is how we use
minerals in our body this is how we
transport minerals from their storage
place to their sight of use in the
colloidal Farm well our plants our crops
don't have much in the way of colloidal
minerals in them because we don't have
any metallic minerals in our soil is
this important well yeah these longli
cultures who live to be 120 to 140 they
have certain common denominators they
all live in high mountain Villages that
are above 8500 to 14,000 ft in elevation
they all have less than 2 inches of
precipitation a year they don't have any
rain they don't have any snow they don't
have any de okay very very dry places
and guess what they get all their
drinking water and all their irrigation
water for their crops from what we call
glacial milk glaciers in every one of
those communities grind up the parent
rock of those mountains about 4 Ines a
year there's more than 60 to 72 minerals
in each one of those places the water
that comes out from underneath those
glaciers is not clear like perer or Evan
water or Poland water or geyser water
you take a glass full of it up and hold
it up it looks like Jersey milk I mean
it is either yellow white or white blue
it looks like milk and is called in
titty ccka I got to say it again in
titty Kaka or Tibet they all call it
glacial milk cuz it looks like milk and
not only have they consumed it drunk it
and got 8 to 12% until they were 35 to
40 then 3 to 5% absorption for 2500 to
5,000 years depending on the culture
more importantly they have irrigated
with it year after year crop after crop
generation after generation for 2500 to
5,000 years they have no diabetes they
have no heart disease no high blood
pressure no arth AR rtis no osteoporosis
no cancer no cataracts no glaucoma they
have no birth
defects they have no jails full of drug
addicts they have no taxes they have no
doctors yet they live to be 120 to 140
without disease are these collidal
minerals important You Bet Your Life
they're important and every time you
don't take them in every day you're
chopping off a few hours or a few days
of your life okay now most people are
not going to go to hanza or Tibet or
titty
Kaka because we don't have K more
kitchens there or even Saturn cars or TV
Changers Channel Changers or electricity
they don't have insulated houses they
don't have central heating or air
conditioning but what they do have is
colloidal
minerals this is Dr wallik with a final
message information gives you the
ability to make decisions with
confidence I hope you've enjoyed my
message by giving your body the proper
raw materials every day you'll be taking
the necessary steps in living healthier
and living longer make the decision to
take control of your personal Health and
Longevity program today colloidal
minerals are not like antibiotics you
don't get a prescription which you use
for 10 days and then you're done your
prescription for colloidal minerals
should only expire when your need for
oxygen expires you need to supp
Implement your diet with the 90
essential nutrients each and every day
of your life millions of people have
heard my message all across the world
and have now decided to make the
consumption of colloidal minerals a
daily ritual just as there are many
manufacturers of aspirin there are now
many manufacturers of vitamins and
mineral supplements be sure to get your
liquid colloidal minerals derived only
from the very best organic plant Source
deposits colloidal minerals are the
mineral Source our bodies were designed
to use not groundup rocks see you will
most likely be supplementing your diet
each and every day don't get caught
paying retail prices my daddy always
said why pay retail when you can buy
wholesale one of my trusted colleagues
will show you how to purchase the
highest quality products wholesale so
you can save gob's money off the retail
price each year the distributor whose
name and phone number is on this
cassette will be happy to help you live
long and prosper